bienvenue dans ce nouveau du taux
aujourd'hui la concurrence
monopolistique à la base de ce cours le
slovan principe d'économie en pratique
très peu de marché sont parfaitement
concurrentiel ou qu'on réponde à des
monopoles pur
la grande majorité des entreprises sont
en situation de concurrence est pourtant
ne sont pas preneuse de prix elles ont
un degré de pouvoir de marché
la plupart des marchés se situe ainsi
entre la concurrence pure et parfaite et
le monopole dans une situation que l'on
qualifie de concurrence imparfaite
au cours de cette vidéo nous allons
considérer le cas de la concurrence
imparfaite ou la concurrence et
monopolistiques en situation de
concurrence monopolistique il existe un
grand nombre de petites entreprises sur
le marché
c'est le cas par exemple des restaurants
des garages des boulangers des épiceries
que l'on trouve un peu partout ces
entreprises qui sont engagés dans une
concurrence intense les unes envers les
autres ne sont pourtant pas dans une
situation de concurrence pure et
parfaite le bien qu'elle offre mais en
effet pas homogène chaque entreprise
offre un produit légèrement différent de
celui de ses concurrents la théorie de
la concurrence monopolistique a été
développé dans les années 30 par
l'économiste américain edward
chamberlain elle peut se comprendre
comme une situation où un grand nombre
d'entreprises sont en concurrence mais
où chacun possède néanmoins un certain
pouvoir de marché d'où l'expression de
concurrence monopolistique chaque
entreprise possède un certain degré de
liberté dans le choix du produit du prix
de ses produits
plusieurs hypothèses fonte la théorie de
la concurrence monopolistique un grand
nombre d'entreprises
de ce fait chaque entreprise représente
une fraction insignifiante du marché
total et dont les choix d'une entreprise
n'influence pas ceux des autres cela
signifie que lorsqu'une entreprise fait
un choix
elle n'a pas à se préoccuper de la
réaction de ses concurrents cette
hypothèse est connu sous le nom d'
hypothèse d' indépendance liberté
d'entrer sur le marché
ici une nouvelle entreprise souhaite
pénétrer le marché
elle est libre de le faire sans aucune
barrière l'information parfaite
les entreprises et les consommateurs
sont parfaitement informés des prix et
des caractéristiques
échanger ses trois premières hypothèses
sont identiques à celles de la
concurrence pure et parfaite
cependant à la différence de cette
dernière les produits ne sont pas
homogènes dans une situation de
concurrence monopolistique la
différenciation de produits correspond à
une situation où chaque entreprise offre
un bien ou un service légèrement
différent de celui de ses concurrents en
conséquence chaque entreprise peut
augmenter ses prix sont perdre tous ses
clients la courbe le demande une
entreprise donnée présente une pente
négative
toutefois la demande qui lui est
adressée est censé être assez élastique
étant donné le grand nombre de
concurrents présents sur le marché vers
lesquels le client peut se retourner au
cas où l'entreprise à vous montrer trop
ses prix le moment est sans doute venu
de vous donner quelques exemples de
situations où la concurrence et
monopolistiques les stations service les
restaurants les boulangeries les salons
de coiffure sont autant d'exemples d une
concurrence monopolistique un cas
classique de la concurrence
monopolistique est une situation avec un
grand nombre d'entreprises mais où
chacune se trouve dans un endroit
distincts par exemple il puis à il peut
y avoir de nombreux coiffeurs dans une
ville mais seulement un par quartier en
ce sens chaque salon de coiffure possède
un monopole local
les clients sont prêts à payer un peu
plus cher afin d'éviter des coûts de
transport pour aller dans un autre
quartier
chaque fois feurs bien concurrence
directe avec les autres disposent ainsi
d'un certain pouvoir de marché la
concurrence monopolistique permet de
comprendre d'autres effets que l'unité
fait du prix sur la demande et sur
l'offre de produits la concurrence entre
les entreprises ne se fait pas seulement
par le biais des prix deux éléments
importants de négligés par les modèles
de la concurrence par les prix
permettent aux entreprises de récupérer
des parts de marché la variété du
produit et le marketing
l'objectif principal d'une entreprise
lorsqu'elle conçoit et développe un
produit et de bien le vendre c'est à
dire de développer un produit avec une
forte demande et de différencier des
produits des concurrents c'est à dire de
développer un produit avec peu de
substitut par exemple pour les
entreprises qui offrent des services la
conception le développement de produits
prennent la forme de c
vi qui sont meilleurs ou au moins
différents de ceux offerts par les
concurrents services personnalisés
horaires d'ouverture différentes tailles
l'objectif principal du marketing et de
vendre le produit
cela suppose évidemment que les
consommateurs soient correctement
informé de son existence de sa
disponibilité mais aussi qu'ils soient
convaincus de l'acheter un marketing
performant n'augmente pas seulement la
demande du produit il vise également à
diminuer son élasticité en le rendant
plus spécifiques
c'est à dire indispensable par rapport
aux autres produits et en fidélisant les
consommateurs le développement de
produits différenciés le marketing le
junior pas seulement des revenus
supplémentaires mais augmente également
les coûts la question est donc de savoir
combien entreprise doit investir en
marketing afin de maximiser ses profits
tout est une question de dosage avant
que nous quittions j'aimerais vous
rappeler la prise de notes indispensable
en complément du visionnage de cette
vidéo ainsi que éventuellement de noter
vos différentes questions afin de les
lui si dès lors du prochain cours de
manière collégiale et participative et
nous nous retrouvons tout de suite pour
le questionnaire et la vérification des
acquis sur ce col j